nackt alarm bei olaf scholz ja ja der
kanzler der stand plötzlich zwischen
nackten brüsten und hat dabei gegrinst
am kanzleramt passiert beim tag der
offenen tür und dabei wollte scholz doch
gar nicht mehr als ein foto mit diesen
beiden frauen fototermin beim tag der
offenen tür aber die haben sich dann die
t shirts runtergerissen einen akt
demonstration eine protestaktion im
mittlerweile patricia wissen wir ein
bisschen mehr über diese frauen von
unseren reportern recherchiert das sind
die frauen von filmen ganz genau und sie
haben diese wenigen sekunden genutzt um
aufmerksam zu machen auch auf
frauenrechte auf den klimawandel das
sind die großen themen und so kam es
dann eben auch zu dieser szene tja und
in diesem fall vor allen dingen
natürlich auch auf den krieg in der
ukraine das sind auch die die vor vielen
jahren nämlich 2013 schon mal bei angela
merkel aufgekreuzt sind damals auf der
hannover messe ganz ähnliche situation
da wird sich im freien aber drin merkel
damals zusammen mit putin noch 213 auf
einer bühne bei der hannover messe
damals hat man den noch eingeladen und
dann kam eben auch die frauen von filmen
vorbei und haben einmal sich die t
shirts vom leib gerissen also das sind
sind ganz bekannte protestgruppe in
diesem fall also wieder gelungen auch
den fokus wieder auf die
gasversorgung für deutschland zu richten
hier der ultimative appell an den
bundeskanzler sofortigen stopp von
putins gas das eben die gruppe femen ja
natürlich gehen diese bäder gerade
überall durchs netz und natürlich auch
entsprechende reaktionen darauf sind
dann sieht man das schon mal den
kanzlern und wie sich die musik
hat er morgen vergessen war so ein
kommentar zum bau oder der grinste noch
ein bisschen schlägt endlich mal was
greifbares
blöden kommentaren ich auch dass mit den
glocken das ließ sich gar nicht erst vor
also aber aber ist ja gut
okay ist das netz es war ein wochenende
zu schaffen doch erstmal sein
es sei aber klar ist jetzt ist er in
kanada und auch das wären wir heute den
ganzen tag hier uns ganz genau anschauen
er trifft das intro hier steigt er aus
er sagt er uns verbindet eine ganz ganz
enge freundschaft denn kanada im
gegenteil zu russland eine verlässliche
demokratie und man will sich austauschen
wie man dort wäre energie krise ein
bisschen wirtschaftsminister dahin
gereist und mit der fetten delegation
wirtschaftsdelegation unter anderem
siemens an bord bosse von uniqa und so
weiter und daran sieht man schon es geht
natürlich wieder ums gas deutschland
will mehr flüssiggas aus kanada also das
ist das ziel der reise dort von habeck
und stolz wie sie sehen können dass
bilder wenige stunden alt dort bei der
ankunft sie wollen das kanadische gas
nach deutschland schauen wir was daraus
wird drei tage dauert die reise haben
wir hier bei bild live natürlich die
ganze zeit im blick
[Musik]